[موسيقى]
سنه 2023 سنه بسيطه اي ان عدد ايامها 365
يوما وعلى هذا الاساس يكون فبراير 28 يوما
وسنها البسيطه تنتهي في نفس اليوم الذي
بدات فيه وهذه السنه ستبدا يوم الاحد
وتنتهي يوم الاحد والسنها الميلاديه سنه
شمسيه تعتمد على دوره شمس الظاهريه حول
الارض فالشمس تعود الى نفس النقطه التي
انطلقت منها كل 365 يوما وربع اليوم
والسنه الميلاديه سميت بهذا نسبه الى
ميلاد سيدنا المسيح ابن مريم عليه السلام
على جنابات هذه الارض نمشي زمان ثم ندفنه
في ثراها وياتي بعدنا قوم وقوم يعيشون
الحياه كما
تراها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وفي عام 2023 يبي حصل عندنا اربع حوادث
كونيه خسوفين وكسوفين يوم الخميس 20 ابريل
كسوف خليط للشمس ما يشاهد عندنا يوم السبت
14 اكتوبر كسوف حلقي للشمس ما يشاهد عندنا
يوم الجمعه خمس مايو خسوف كاذب للقمر
يشاهد عندنا ويوم السبت 28 اكتوبر خسوف
جزئي يشاهد عندنا لحظه كسوف الشمس ما تنفع
شموع حتى تعود الشمس من بعد غيبه اقضي
هدوء الليل
يقول صبحي
يتيبه
[موسيقى]